(mellow music)
- I've heard a lot about this idea
that peanut butter can
act as a cheap replacement
for moisturizing shaving cream.
- Today, we're shaving with peanut butter.
- There are a bunch of YouTube videos
spanning many years of this thing,
and they're like, it's
a hack, it's a hack.
- I love peanut butter.
(laughs)
- It feels really good
on my skin, I must admit.
- Uh, do what I usually do when I shave.
Oh, oh, okay, hmm.
- This, oh wow, I don't know.
- [Woman In Dark Denim
Shirt] I mean, it's working.
- Oh, I put way too much on.
- Immediate thoughts was, oh, it's smooth,
oh, it's getting stuck, oh, now it's
not really doing anything.
- Maybe you need less peanut
butter than what I have on.
- I used way too much,
so I'm putting the slack
to moisturize this bottom leg.
- Look at it.
Can you see that?
There's just lumps of peanut butter,
like spilling out of the razor.
It looks foul.
- It's a bit thick, and it's kind of
going into my razor right now, so.
- I mean, it feels like it's
dragging, but it is working.
- I mean, that feels pretty smooth.
(laughs)
I'm like, what?
- [Woman In Light Denim
Shirt] Oh, yeah, it's smooth.
I'm gonna keep going.
- The problem is that we have too much.
- A little bit goes a long way with this.
- So, my theory is that
you're using the peanut butter
to kind of grease your arm, so that
it's just like an oily sheen.
That's quite lovely.
- The only thing I would
say is a down point,
I can't stop touching my leg.
Like, it's really nice.
- What money you would save
not getting shaving cream,
you would end up spending on razors.
So, I think it just
depends on what you want.
- Cream is two bucks more,
and I'd rather just get that
and not clog my sink.
- That being said, like,
this feels really nice.
- It's like more silky
than I use shave gel,
because I fell like it's moisturized me
more than shave gel does, which is insane.
- But, super messy and gross.
(upbeat music)